foreign
in Mumbai India
hi I'm a patreon subscriber my name is
rukmini and I'm from Mumbai India how do
you deal with misery arising from memory
from involuntary reminders of mistakes
from the past
you know mistakes are a real fascinating
thing because when we make a mistake and
we don't learn from it what happens we
keep making the same mistake our friend
Drew who did the music for both of our
films him and Nate they formed this band
vve but his first band which I really
love parlorhawk that he had this amazing
line I learned a lot of good lessons
here that I choose to forget and isn't
that true we learn a lesson and of
course when it becomes inconvenient that
lesson goes by the wayside but here's
the opposite of that a mistake ceases to
be a mistake as soon as it actually
becomes a lesson as soon as you've
learned something from it it's no longer
a mistake and so rukmini if you have
actually learned your lesson and it's
moved you forward in a way so that
you're not going to make that same
mistake then you can simply Let It Go
how do you let go you stop clinging to
that mistake because you realize it
wasn't a mistake after all
um
yeah you know a memory is not an
objective recollection of past events
it's an imperfect recollection of past
events plus a personal narrative about
how that event fits into the broader
story of our lives and the way you let
go of a memory that brings pain is you
recognize that this is not me seeing it
as it actually is in some objective
sense it's my story that brings the pain
and that story can be changed that story
can be negotiated that story can be
tinkered with and you know you think
about
um all success stories they none of them
mean anything if they don't have some
kind of embarrassing failure in them
that's what makes the success stories
interesting now the person with the
success story can say hey there was this
time where the first time I went on
stage I completely bombed and put my
foot in my mouth or the first time you
know I I asked out the lady that turned
out to be my wife I completely
embarrassed myself and she laughed at me
if you just remember that event it can
be like a really bad thing but what
makes the success story interesting they
contextualize it by saying and this is
what that means it impacted me this way
and I learned this and I got better as a
result of that and I went on to achieve
this accomplish that create XYZ whatever
it may be and so
it's not failure until you've accepted
it as final if there's something bad or
unpleasant that has happened in your
experience just know that that is not
the story that is only a component in
your story and you have the power to
decide how you're going to label that
and what meaning you're going to assign
to that that's the part that you get to
choose you don't delete the memory from
your brain but you let it go by adding
something to it namely an empowering
story of where it's going to take you
because of how you're going to use that
experience
you know the best way to not feel guilty
stop doing things that make you feel
guilty I mean that's that's how I look
at it for me I think about how poorly
I've treated people in the past and it's
embarrassing and it's it's uh
it's shameful in a way I don't feel
shame over it because I'm not that
person anymore but there is there is
some shamefulness that I that I express
with that but the way that I was able to
get over that is I'm like oh I'm gonna
stop treating people poorly
and I'm gonna go out of my way to like
do what I can for people
that way I won't feel guilty about
treating people poorly and I promise you
like if you uh Rook mini if you if you
go out of your way to like
um be the person that you really want to
be in that you know that you are like
you can start to let go of that guilt
for sure there's another layer to that
as well because you just talked about
two components there one is you stop
treating people poorly and that's
actually the main component sure because
as soon as you stop treating people
poorly it's not like you have to
give them effusive praise throughout
every day because that can also come off
as disingenuous that's not what we're
talking about right and so what you
really did is you decluttered the
meanness the the lack of concern or lack
of compassion or whatever it wasn't even
about treating them nicely yeah it was
about merely dropping that behavior yeah
that turned them off and also turned you
off by the way now why do we do that
almost always because of
self-righteousness I'm gonna put myself
on a pedestal because I feel small
that's the reason we put ourselves on
the pedestal because I feel like a tiny
person and so I need to raise myself up
to so you can see me eye to eye or you
know what I want to look down on you so
I can feel powerful I can feel like I'm
in control I can feel like I'm better
than you and so I start treating you
poorly not knowing that I'm treating you
poorly merely because I feel
insignificant well if you simply realize
that you are significant regard
regardless of what other people think
about you whether or not you get their
acceptance their veneration their praise
their quote unquote love right you are
already enough you are already
significant then that is enough and if
you really want to love other people you
can simply see them you can notice them
without trying to manipulate them and
certainly without looking down on them
yeah
um I think about the May song where he
says
fools wouldn't listen to My Demo but now
they want to drive in My Limo and one of
the things that that lyric illustrates
is that you can always put a comma
behind a negative past and a butt after
that comma and you can add something
positive to it that makes that negative
memory something that is an exciting and
essential part of your story and Ryan
just did it he said I used to do things
that make me feel bad comma but now I'm
a better person than I used to be now I
do things that serve people that help
them and that Empower them and we can do
that with anything I used to make this
kind of mistake I used to treat people
like this I used to embarrass myself
like that comma but now I'm a better
human being because of how I chose to
react and respond to it you can always
put that comma and that butt with
something positive after it and it
transforms the memory into something
that you don't want to let go you want
to hold on to it as an inspiring part of
an empowering story yeah you know what's
interesting is when I started to go out
of my way to like be a different person
a lot of people didn't trust me um I
mean they were just looking at me like
oh you're a minimalist now okay like
like I've I've seen what you do
and I'm just not buying it right yeah
because your previous pattern didn't
match the new aspiration exactly so you
know I had to push through that
um because then I started to doubt
myself too like oh maybe I'm a fraud and
um but I had to push through it and I'm
glad I did and you know what like all
those people who
um you know maybe were raising an
eyebrow or not trusting me um you know I
can't think of anyone who now doesn't
like see me for who I am and uh yeah but
it was difficult to push through that
like I could see where maybe someone
would uh their Journey would be a paused
because you know they're trying to be a
different person and people are like
stop trying to be someone different we
know who you are I mean it made me pause
for a second but uh pushing through was
it was great I'm glad I did it did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalists private podcasts
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com the minimalists or click the
link in the description your support
keeps our podcast and YouTube Channel
100 advertisement free
[Music]